darfst nicht das ist ein Geheimnis gar
keine einheitung reden wir machen jetzt
Test da ist Dings in meinem Haar kann
das sein ja ich bin im
[Musik]
Kopf wir starten jetzt zu allererst mit
unserem Keksboden und dafür nehme ich
meinen Backrahmen und stelle ihn auf 25
x 25 cm ein geb das jetzt hier einfach
auf mein cakeboard oder auf irgendeine
Unterlage die ihr gerade da habt die
sollte halt nur komplett gerade sein das
ist ganz wichtig das kommt jetzt kurz
zur Seite und als nächstes brauchen wir
natürlich Kekse ich habe jetzt hier
keine normalen Butterkekse sondern diese
diese dran riechen kennt ihr das diese
karamellpekulatius Kekse
Stereo heißen die glaube ich GI bei Kauf
auf jeden Fall und da könnt ihr jetzt
entweder das hier in einen Beutel tun
und dann ein bisschen Frust rauslassen
und draufhen so dass sie richtig schön
fein werden oder ihr habt vielleicht
sogar so ein Mixer zu Hause dann könnt
ihr den benutzen ich find so krass ich
warte nur noch darauf dass der kaputt
geht der ist schon allen Seiten
gebrochen aber hams hat mir den vor 10
Jahren ich glaube es ist echt schon vor
über 7 Jahren hatte mir das mal zum
Geburtstag geschenkt weil ich immer so
gern gebacken habe und to to to hält
sich bis heute ich werde jetzt einfach
nur die Kekse schön fein malen und dann
mit der Butter vermengen und dann
einfach hier auf den Boden geben und
schön flach
[Musik]
anpressen
den kekboden habe ich jetzt erstmal zur
Seite gestellt und wir machen jetzt die
Cheesecake Füllung dafür benötigen wir
Doppelrahmfrischkäse und Sahne am besten
sind beide Zutaten jetzt schön kalt ich
muss mal kurz mein teigschauber
zusammenfemeln das gebe ich jetzt hier
einmal in die Küchenmaschine ihr dürft
natürlich auch euer Handrührgerät
benutzen wenn ihr jetzt keine
Küchenmaschine da habt das funktioniert
genauso gut dauert halt nur ein bisschen
länger so und da gebe ich dann gleich
auch noch noch Puderzucker für die Süße
mit
[Musik]
dazu wichtig ist dass ihr erstmal
wirklich bei niedrigster Stufe erstmal
alles miteinander verrührt damit es eine
homogene Masse wird und dann geht ihr
Schritt für Schritt immer eine Stufe
höher und könnt das alles zusammen steif
[Musik]
schlagen ja ich würde es gerne
weiterbacken darf ich oder darfst nicht
das ist ein Geheimnis das ist ein
Geheimnis hab schon gerade gesehen man
hat bestimmt schon mal gesehen und so
ein bisschen
angedeutet salted Caramel fehlte noch im
Kikis cream Sortiment und die hier kommt
jetzt zum Einsatz in der Creme und ihr
wisst ja immer wenn wir eine neue cream
vorstellen muss haben s immer dabei sein
ich bin ganz ehrlich Z ich habe das
jetzt zum ersten Mal es ist heute
angekommen wir haben direkt heute Video
gemacht und ich jetzt zum ersten mal so
eine vollkommener Pracht das habe ich
mal selber n gedrucken guck wie es
aussieht W mir gerade frisch geliefert
das also heute kam die Meldung von Julia
aus dem Lager Kik Cream ist da und ich
hatte hier immer nur unsere Proben von
der Entwicklung und so weiter ja und das
ist jetzt wirklich so und wenn ihr euch
jetzt und wenn ihr euch jetzt wundert
warum jetzt das Logo jetzt bisschen
kleiner ist als die anderen oder sonst
was wir haben immer verschiedene
Hersteller wir haben die gleichen
Hersteller warum ja weil nicht jeder
alles kann gleich gut kann z.B können
die Türken die Haselnusskerne am besten
und die Italiener können z.B eben unsere
cocoscream oder unsere sal Caramel cream
am besten und so ist rund um den Globus
verteilt die Produktion von unserer
cream deswegen kriegt ihr immer die
besten von besten Cremes der Welt so
aber genug gequatscht kein richtiges
Deutsch aber egal genug gequatscht warum
haben wir das gemacht also wir habenich
lange dran entwickelt das hat lange
gedauert weil es ist total schwierig die
perfekte ja ich sag mal Salznote da
reinzkommen ohne dass es zu salzig ist
oder dass es zu wenig salzig ist möchte
auch gerne noch ein Löffel mehr Salz
drin genau da ist jetzt mehr Salz drin
und sie schmeckt wirklich also das ist
eine perfekte Komponente aus süßem
Aufstrich aber auch natürlich wieder mal
zum Backen geeignet und so eine leichte
se Salznote also ihr müsst es einfach
mal alles Z zungeen das schmeckt so
lecker ich kenne keine vergleichbare
cream ja ich sag euch ja immer ich will
immer besser werden als das was bereits
auf dem Markt ist und diese cream hat
eine absolute Daseinsberechtigung weil
sowas eben meinen Augen nicht gibt mega
lecker mega mega es stehen hier zwei
Wörter die mir so ein bisschen das Herz
brechen aber es kommt wie immer auf euch
an ob diese cream eine Limited Edition
bleibt oh ja oder ob wir sie dauerhaft
im Sortiment haben ja ich verlinke es
euch auf jeden Fall ham machst du wieder
ein Bundle also ich w kein drck machen
aber bestellt lieber vielw frage ich
machst du machst du ein Bundle weil
Bundle kann man sich auch mal ein
bisschen was sparen und das find ich
eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee und Bo
Leute die schmeckt so geil die schmeckt
einfach nur also hört auf meine Worte
SAS no probier wir freuen uns auf EU
Feedback unbedingt unbedingt es wä auch
cool wenn ihr dann nach dem Probieren
wirklich unter diesem Video euer
Feedback schreibt das würde mir echt
viel bedeuten und ich will am Liesten
drin baden aber das kann ich leider
nicht da bräuchten wir ein paar Gläser
mehr für und deswegen packe ich das
jetzt hier in die Creme rein und ham so
du kannst dann gleich zum Taste das
[Musik]
wieder die salted Caramel cream jetzt
wirklich nur noch ein paar Sekunden
unterrühren so dass ich das eben nicht
überschlägt guck mal die Masse ist jetzt
noch ein bisschen weich ich habe auch
gar kein Sahnefest mit reingegeben weil
ich jetzt einfach möchte dass das Ganze
während der Kühlzeit eine richtig schöne
feste aber dennoch cremige Konsistenz
bekommt und das kriegt ihr eben wenn ihr
da wirklich dem ganz viel Zeit gebt also
wirklich mindestens 6 Stunden ihr könnt
das ganze auch am Vortag machen das kann
auch die ganze Nacht kühlen oder 24
Stunden das ist auch kein Problem falls
ihr das Vorbereiten müsst ist ja auch
ganz cool wegen des Zeitplans quasi dass
man einfach dann kein Stress hat
irgendwie am nächsten Tag genau und das
coole ist dass die salted Caramel cream
jetzt dann auch schön fest wird also sie
bewegt jetzt nicht dass die ganze
Füllung hier irgendwie auseinander geht
oder so und so ist das bei allen meinen
creams dass ihr da einfach Problem
problemlos ob Backrezepte oder nobak ist
alles kein Problem könnt ihr alles
verwenden so ich nehme jetzt hier noch
meine Winkelpalette Streiche das glatt
und nach der Kühlzeit mache ich noch
einen schönen salted Caramel Guss oben
[Musik]
drüber nach der Kühlzeit ist die Glasur
auch ganz schnell zubereitet ihr müsst
einfach nur die salted Caramel cream bei
geringer Wattzahl für ca 15 bis 20
Sekunden in der Mikrowelle erwärmen und
dann auf die abgekühlte Oberfläche geben
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr das ganze
dann auch noch mit fsch dekorieren ich
habe hier Karamell fatsch gefunden könnt
ihr aber auch weglassen weil der
Karamellgeschmack ist auf jeden Fall da
und es tut auf jeden Fall dem dem
gespruch es tut auf jeden Fall dem
Geschmack kein Abbruch wollte ich sagen
wenn ihr das weglasst so die Kühlzeit
ist jetzt rum also auch die zweite
Kühlzeit dass die Glasur fest wird die
beträgt nur 10 Minuten die ist jetzt
auch rum und endlich Leute kann ich mir
diesen backformlöser nehmen und nachdem
ihr dann den backraben gelöst habt
einfach nur noch durch neun oder in neun
Stückchen Teilen besser hat gesagt und
dann rufe ich den hams und ich freue
mich so sehr auf den Taste
[Musik]
Test so jetzt machen wir den taste ich
warte gar nicht so lange ich
okay ich brauche gar keine Einleitung
reden wir machen jetzt t also diese
cheesecakeemasse ist richtig schön weiß
da ist eine Dings in meinem HA kann das
sein ist Wesp meinem Haar oh sorry tut
mir leid aber die war richtig richtig
vibriert muss Video gucken okay noch
mal sorry okay mal die W mag das nicht
noch mal machen so
weiteren ich habe gar keine die war Kopf
drin Spin Kopf ja okay das glaube ich
jetzt nicht Spin im Kopf e Leute es ist
eine 14 von ze sage ich euch wie es ist
es schmeckt so richtig wie als wä weißt
wo wir in New York waren UPS weß wo wir
in New York waren da haben wir so
richtig mal so Desserts probiert die so
richtig America Style hatten die war so
richtig no was anderes nicht immer das
gleiche nicht immer schokoanille Erdbeer
ich auch krass ist so lecker ich hab
noch nie so eine Creme gegessen die so
salzig war also jetzt nicht negativ
salzig das hat diese perfekte
Salznote süß und D kommt bisschen we
komm ja ich würde sagen es ich würde
sagen es ist so wirklich
97% süß und 2% salzig was das Ganze
wieder so richtig rund macht rund macht
genau e das ist so ein G das ist so ein
geiler Geschmack Leute ich bin so am
schwärmen ich finde das so einer der
leckersten Schnitten ich muss aufpassen
D nicht bei jedem Video sage weil ich
toppe das irgendwie gefühlt von Woche zu
Woche aber das schmeckt so geil ich
krass weil einfach für mich neues
Erlebnis neue Geschmack hab noch nie
gehabt muss ehrlich sagen und ich wusste
nicht dass sowas fehlt krass ne
Geschmack oder S ich sagen hat wirklich
noch gefehlt du bist eine heiere
Schnitte als der Ken
nein oh mein
Gott was für ein Humor ich muss ehrlich
sagen nein das ist echt lecker wirklich
wirklich eine Sache die ich wirklich
ehrlich zugeben muss dass diese diese
fatsch Teile nicht sein müssen die sind
lecker ja aber ich finde dass man hier
durch den Keksboden diesen Crunch hat
dann hat man diese richtig leckere
cheesecakeemasse und den geilen Guss und
eigentlich ist es da auch ohne perfek W
sind die eigentlich von ög genau Ö muss
nicht sein sage ich euch sage ich euch
wie es ist könnt ihr auch weglassen wenn
ihr die nicht findet aber es ist so ein
geiles Rezept also ich habe zu viel
gequatscht wir lassen die Leute jetzt
mal gehen das Ganze nachmchen also ich
find es muss auch nicht sein diese
Dinger aber s gehen halt optisch was her
also optisch sieht halt cool
aus so für die volle Transparenz jetzt
noch eine kleine Info ihr wisst ja dass
wir immer ganz viel an unseren
Rezepturen experimentieren das Projekt
hat jetzt wann haben wir damit gestartet
Anfang
2 nee 23 m also wirklich fast 10 Monate
11 Monate hat gedauert be genau und es
kann sein dass die Farbe sich noch mal
ein bisschen ändert bei der nächsten
charge dass wir dann noch mal an einer
stell Schraube drehen geschmacklich
bleibt es aber so die Cremigkeit ist
auch perfekt es kann wirklich nur sein
dass falls ihr ein Glas in den Händen
haltet das doch ein bisschen rötlicher
ist da braucht ihr euch nicht wundern
weil wir sind da wirklich noch bei der
Sache in einem Prozess aber
geschmacklich Cremigkeit Haltbarkeit
alles ist perfekt an dieser ich wollte
gerade sagen am Ende steht der Geschmack
und der ist hammer
ja
weggehauen Hammer we einfach wegauen so
ich würde mal sagen wünsche euch viel
Spaß beim nachmach und sage bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss peace and
[Musik]
out